It's gone!
Zack may be walking but he faces another barrier to further progress.
Imagine what it's like for an infant to understand so very little of what's going on around it...
Hello. I'm looking for some lamps.
...to feel lost and excluded from the social world.
The closest we get to it is a holiday abroad.
These are too old; I want something new.
Trouble is, you can only get so far with mime and pointing.
No?
No.
Will you take me to the pyramids?
Yes, okay.
As a child, one thing you lack is...
...an accurate way of explaining your desires, exactly what you feel;...
...what you really want or any way really of telling your parents what to get for you.
What you need of course are words.
Every human culture has depended on them, be they spoken or written...
...like these hieroglyphics.
Words and language are the most important thing a child will ever learn.
Not just words to describe things you can point at like sand or rock,...
...but words to describe abstract things:...
...your past, your future, your fears, your hopes;...
...words to describe discoveries and ideas...
...to communicate into other people...
...down the generations, ever expanding the wealth of human knowledge and experience.
The whole world we have built is built upon language.
And yet, it all begins so simply.